♪
- En 1972, quatre jeunes
à Disraeli, dans la région
de Chaudière-Appals,s,s,
pour photographier durant
trois mois des gens ordinaires.
- On a choisi Disraeli
parce qu'on vot t t une place
qui n'était pas urbaine,pas trot
pas mourante comme beaucoup
de petites places au Québec.
"cross section" de la société
québécoise
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ils captent sans fard, mais
avec authenticité la réalité
des villageois. Sans le savoir,
ils éc
marquant de l'histoire de
la photographie au Québec.
MICHEL CAMPEAU, photographe
on invente, de mon point de vue,
on invente la photphphphie
contemporaine au Canada.
photographe
- On se promenait, pc'c'c'était
vraiment simple : on échangeait
avec les gens, puis on leurenent
d'être photographiés.
ROGER CHARBONNEAU, photographe
- Les gens quelquefois disaient:
"J
je suis habillé en vieux."
Non, non, c'est ça, justement,
on veut te photographier dans
ton état de tous les jours.
des photos, la polémique éclate.
Les noeseses locaux,
peu habitués à des photos
aussi réalistes, s'indignentoiet
du village. Dans la presse,
deux visions s'affrontent :
doit-on représenter le réel
ou renvoye- C'était une époque e
forte au Québec, c'est le début
des années 70, donc c'était
un petit peu représenter ça.
important, puis ça vaut la peine
de pgrgrgraphier tout le monde
leur quotidien.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'ex
présente 144 photographies,
dont 67 inédites, de même que
des enregistrements audio
captés à l'époque.
ZOË TOUSIGNANT, conserv. coll.
Photographieéeéeée McCord Stew.
- Ces enregistrements audio-là
ont été comme perdus pendant
retrouvés dans la préparation
de l'exposition.
- 50 ans plus tard,
ce travail documentaire précieux
et les questionsiqiqiques
cruciales qu'il a soulevées.
- Forcément, déjà au départ,
photographique indéniable,d'unee
est venue donner quelque chose,
un supplément d'âmesesesesesesee
au pourquoi de la photographie,
au comment nous photographions,
pour qui nous photographions.
à l'affiche du Musée McCord
jusqu'au 19 février.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.